-Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching!
Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much
going on right now this week.
Former President Trump
was arrested
and charged here in New York.
Plus...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, Easter is on Sunday.
The new "Super Mario Bros."
movie is now in theaters.
And I just heard the NBA says
it will no longer test players
for weed.
-Ooh.
-There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up, Trump's arrest.
He's facing 34 charges
related to hush-money payments.
He's in real trouble, and
every time he opens his mouth
to talk about the case,
his lawyers say...
Jesus.
[ Laughter ]
That's who Easter's all about.
Families come together
to celebrate.
And, of course, on Sunday,
the Easter Bunny
will show up and shout...
"It's a-me."
That's Mario's catchphrase.
And you can hear it in the all
new "Super Mario Bros. Movie."
I hope there's a scene
on Rainbow Road.
Flying down that colorful track
makes you feel...
high as a kite.
[ Laughter ]
That's what you can be
in the NBA
because they're no longer
testing players for marijuana.
It's crazy to think
a couple years ago
smoking weed could land you...
in jail.
[ Laughter ]
Trump pled not guilty
on Tuesday,
but as the judge
read the charges,
it became pretty clear that his
best legal defense is to...
pray.
[ Laughter ]
I really hope the Easter Bunny
brings me
some Easter chocolate
and marshmallow Peeps.
That would be so...
dope.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, marijuana
is fair game now.
So after every game, the teams
are gonna head to White...
Castle -- that's where
Peach lives -- in a castle.
This movie can make
175 million bucks
in one weekend.
Wow.
Nobody's made so much money
in so little time since...
Stormy Daniels.
[ Laughter ]
Trump gave her hush money
for their one-night stand,
but she still told everyone
that his junk looks like...
a mushroom, kind of like Toad,
who's in the movie,
and so is Yoshi.
Maybe we'll see him hatch from
one of his famous green...
eggs.
Kids put them
in their Easter baskets,
along with candy, presents
and, of course...
grass.
[ Laughter ]
In conclusion, karts are driven,
big decision, he is risen.
Have fun in prison.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's right.
Trump's arrest was
the big story of the week.
And I saw that it gave
all the cable news networks
a massive spike in ratings.
The anchors on CNN
were so excited, they were like,
"Wait. People can see me?"
Meanwhile, after visiting
New York to protest
Trump's arrest, Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
called the city
a terrible place
that is disgusting,
filthy, and repulsive.
[ Audience oohs ]
But don't worry.
Things got a lot better here
after she left.
[ Laughter ]
We're good now. We're back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some big sports news.
Today in Augusta, Georgia,
the Masters golf tournament
kicked off.
It's just nice
to see someone get hushed
without being paid $130,000.
Well, this is cool. Meta
just shared a new A.I. model
that can detect objects
that it's never seen before.
Yeah, stuff
it's never seen before,
like Bigfoot
or the Loch Ness Monster
or someone as beautiful as you.
Come here often? Me neither.
Sorry. My shoe's untied.
Just kidding.
But now that I'm down here...
marry me?
We could live in a little house
by the sea.
Laugh. Cry. Grow old together.
Your memory will go,
but every day,
I'll tell you the story
of how we met.
And for one brief moment,
we'll dance again.
We'll die in our sleep,
holding hands.
"Welcome to heaven,"
God will say.
"But I'm afraid
I can't let you guys in."
"What?"
"You didn't post enough.
You barely poked anyone.
And your profile pictures,
they're all from 2013."
And that's when we'll realize...
he's immortal, he's all-knowing.
Yup, that's right.
God is Meta AI.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Did you guys see this?
Starbucks just introduced
a new line
of olive oil-infused coffee,
and customers are complaining
that the drink
gives them stomach issues.
Yeah, but don't worry.
I hear Dunkin's
new Crisco Coolatta is great.
Of course, Starbucks
is already taking advantage.
They're now selling
a Peptoccino, which is...
Well, listen to this.
A city councilor in Boston
wants to prevent heavy drinking
by banning the sale
of miniature liquor bottles.
To be fair, in Boston,
a miniature liquor bottle
is just a normal-sized
liquor bottle.
Hey, I heard that due
to a pilot shortage,
some experts want Congress
to bump up the retirement age
for pilots from 65 to 67.
Yeah, it's not good
when your pilot's like,
"We're flying through
a huge cloud.
Oh, wait. That's my cataracts."
[ Laughter ]
You'll know
when your pilot's older
when they say, "We'll be
landing in three minutes.
I want to make sure
I'm home before 'Jeopardy!'"
And, finally,
speaking of pilots,
I heard about a pilot
who was able to safely land
his plane after a deadly cobra
slithered up his shirt.
It's never good when you fasten
your seat belt, and it moves.
Yep, he landed the plane
while his copilot
did something
even more heroic --
filmed it for TikTok.
We have a great show.
Give it up for the Roots,
everybody!
[ The Roots rapping ]
♪♪
-Yes! We have
a great show tonight.
She stars in the HBO Max series
"The Other Two,"
and she is hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend with musical guest
Jonas Brothers.
Molly Shannon is here!
-Come on! Whoo!
-Come on!
-Love it.
Love it, love it, love it.
-I love Molly Shannon!
-Ohh.
-She is the greatest. I can't
wait to catch up with her.
Plus, you can see him
in the ABC series "Will Trent."
He plays Will Trent.
It returns with new episodes
April 18th.
Ramón Rodriguez
is joining us tonight.
"Will Trent."
-And we got great stand-up
from Sophie Buddle, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
This week,
in honor of tonight's guest's
Molly Shannon's show
"The Other Two"
about a dysfunctional
brother and sister,
I sent out the hashtag
#MySiblingsWeird.
And I asked you to tweet out
your funniest
weird sibling stories.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MySiblingsWeird tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. The first one
is from @Caroline--
Oh, there's some weird ones.
-Yeah.
-This first one's from
@CarolineJosephs. She says...
[ Hisses ]
-Ssss!
-This one's from @DJTheOldMan.
-Ooh.
-They say...
[ Applause ]
-Swallow 'em?
I don't know. It is weird.
This one's from @Stillwatergirl.
No sparkling. Thank you.
-Oh, yeah.
-I'm -- I'm Stillwater Girl.
-Yeah.
-Or maybe she's still
Water Girl.
It's like, "Hey, remember years
ago you were Water Girl?"
"No, I'm still Water Girl."
-It's fine.
-Or like
still water runs deep.
-Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Deep Girl.
-Or Stillwater the band from...
-"Almost Famous."
-Yeah.
She's a big fan of the movies.
-Love it.
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
That's fun, man.
-Come on.
-"Yeah. You haven't met Norman?
Oh, he's so cool."
-He told that to his therapist.
-This one's from
@LiterallyHatGuy. He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @Robnhood6.
They say...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-God bless, right? God bless.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @gumgumerson.
-Oh. Great.
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
This one's from @Sloan-B-07.
They say...
[ Laughter ]
-Don't! Don't you breathe!
-Rules are rules! Yeah.
This one's from @valerielyn77.
She says...
[ Audience groans ]
-Ooh. Ohh.
-Come on.
-[Chuckling] Ohh, no.
-This last one's
from @jennifurray. She says...
-There you have it, everybody.
Those are "Tonight Show"
Hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.